HEY WHAT'S GOING ON IS BILL BYRNE It's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday June 19th 2017.
What's going on.
How are you doing.
How are you.
What's up.
Oh that's great. That's you doing good.
How you doing. Good. It gets good.
I'm doing great. I'm actually
recording this on Sunday June 18th.
Forty nine years old my first fuckin five.
Day first Father's Day.
Ah cheese. Bill what did
you do. God bless you.
You're in the clubhouse fucking turn. You
finally became a dad. What did you do.
I had a great day.
You know they go all out for Mother's Day.
There she has brunch after brunch shifted
this after that I went over to a car
show over on Rodeo
Drive Rodeo Drive renewable or road a
road Rodale drive the fancy Sharansky
place.
Evidently they have a fathers
station car show every Father's Day.
Obviously if it's going to
call Father's Day car show.
Yes they've had it every year and of
course I never went I was never a dad I
never even heard about the fucking
thing so I was not on the email list.
You know Billy the Kid was as you guys
called me back in the day as if five
months ago you could still call me that.
So I was never on the email list and
god damn and I was like I'm going over
there.
So we head over there and you know it's
like you know the beautiful people out
beautiful people and me
rich rich as fuck.
Yeah.
Beverly Hills they call
it the Beverly Hills
car show and I got to tell you
man is fucking beautiful cars.
I was either gonna go to the Peterson
museum I was gonna do that I figure I can
go to the Peterson museum anytime.
This is the Father's Day one I gotta
go to that one and then I'll do the
Peterson later right.
So I fucking go over there.
Peterson museum by the way.
Right down next to that place
that's right where Biggie got shot.
Wilshire in fucking Fairfax.
So anyways so I'm over there Rodeo Drive.
I'm checking it out right there's all
these rich people you know there's all
these beautiful fucking
you know I don't know what.
You know walking around God knows how
old they are they're really getting go
with the plastic surgery man they're
really really getting fucking I was still
with some amazing old looking
women walking around you know.
Weird Forever 21 shit that they bought it.
You know I don't know one of those
stores up and down the block right.
So we're walking around.
You know it's fucking hilarious.
Every restaurant was closed over there.
Like fuck the dads say like five
food trucks even over there.
And I guess it's the
daddy doesn't give a shit.
Show me a couple of fuckin babble Beals
shown the Lincoln from Entourage which
they had over there which
was fucking cool as shit.
One of the great cars out there the
Continental suicide doors and all that.
Not a convertible guy but you
know who work for the show.
The overhead shot iconic
shot at this point.
They had the Eleanor car from Gone in 60
seconds but I liked I like Oh I always
like the weird shit
I saw like a 19 What the fuck was a 1961
62 63 Mercedes Benz limousine and out
of everything that was there there was a
Tucker there there was a fuck in one of
those mid feel like a 55 Mercedes
going you know a bunch of Ferrari's
Lamborghini similar all those weird years
in the 70s those ones Adam Corolla has
a lot of them I don't mean weird like
they're not good looking it's just like
you know we saw Mr. racing car and then
to me it was for me I just felt it went
right to Magnum P.I.
it was until I did Crowley's podcast back
in the day when I saw the Lamborghini
and froze I was just like one of these
things like oh this is that this one this
is that one from like
the like the late 60s.
So now they're cool as shit.
He was ahead of the curve by the way I
was watching a local newscast out here
and
Adam charisma free Plugger Adam Corolla
was on and he was promoting he's got a
he's got a documentary on the 24 hours
of the mines in the 1950s when Ford
decided that they were gonna guest compete
and see what they could do over there
and they came out with the four G T
he's got this great skin getting rave
reviews and he has another documentary
that he already put out about the racing
life of Paul Newman and if you go to his
website I believe it's chassis dot com
something if you just put an Adam Corolla
mans it's gonna come up and what I
love is all I could find on the website
was just the DVD which is great for me
as an old man I don't like that fucking
Hey you download it and then it's in the
air and somehow it's on my computer and
then I dumped some orange juice on the
keyboard and I don't own it anymore I
like the DVD I don't know I I'm an old man
I like the DVD that's like having the
gold behind you money so had I known about
this I would have asked for both of those
for Father's Day so instead I'm just
going to buy it myself.
So anyways I fucking go over there and
they've got this Mercedes Benz like 1961
62 63 some in the early 60s and it's a
it's a limousine it's fucking black it's
got this I took a video I know I always
say when I post it then I always forget
that I say I'm going to do a promo try
to remember you're had this beautiful red
interior and
it was just I was like that that right
there that's what the fuck is it the
older I get as much as I enjoy
driving I don't enjoy driving in L.A.
because the traffic is just
fucking insane and my wife my wife.
She obeys all the time so I'm getting
used to this jumping in a car and somebody
else is driving you know I
want to go out with her and
I get all his business done be breaking
people's balls back on some text you
know call it back fucking Joe DeRosa
roses some shit better call saul Joe De
Rosa for your consideration is the fucking
veterinarian on that wonderful show
turn email calls business
shit all of that and
you know you always read out parties
these fucking people are here the these
moguls like the Ryan Seacrest out here
they they don't fucking drive they have a
drive are
they sit in the back and they get
shit done they pull the curtain right.
They just back there.
They get like the Janet Jackson headset
on their fucking show firing off emails.
They're buying stocks I don't know
what they're doing back there.
I'm not a mogul it's like they're gonna
tell you I can tell someone I'd be a
mogul and everybody's a mogul and what
you use silver you're just a regular guy.
Next thing you know you've stopped at a
red light you look it over like is that
Ryan Seacrest driving his own fucking car.
What happened.
That this guy had 17 fuckin TV shows.
Anyways I could really get into
that to be honest with you.
Who's getting who I'm not a mogul.
I'm just fucking lazy and I don't know.
I think there's just two types of people
as they get older there's the person
that just you know takes up cycling in
rock climbing and they take like a fuckin
glass blown class of some shit you know
and then there's other people being like
you know what I fuckin tired man.
You know I like to chill if I get another
forty nine years or whatever I get.
You know I'm on the back nine. Who's
kidding who. Forty nine times two is 98.
I want to make one hundred
staying positive. Who can do.
All right
like I'm on the 12th hole.
Fuck wants to drive in L.A..
It's fucking horrible.
I would actually thoroughly enjoy and I
would just enjoy it if you had that kind
of loot if redo an old fucking
beautiful car like that.
You restore it you bring it back to life
and then you just in the back you know
you got you got you know you got a little
humidor some fuckin cigars you know
couple of your favorite little fuckin
accoutrements being the booze there
and you just fuck it whatever it is.
Drive around
Well whatever your driver's name is you
still column James every fucking every
chauffeur was always named that would
be great. You want to go to the movies.
You know I drink too much already man.
There's no way I can handle always
having a designated driver I begin fuckin
steward go into the supermarket.
Speaking of which Billy no fun.
Oh Jesus Jesus Christ was seven days in
seven fucking days and last night he had
a couple glasses of wine.
We went out with another couple.
What am I supposed to do.
Everybody you know have an Italian meal
and I suppose I have a little Borroloola.
What am I supposed to eat a couple of
those you know and I don't even fucking
like mine.
It's just it's just it's always reminding
you of the hangover it's gonna give
you. Turns your teeth Grey.
But I actually enjoyed.
That's the one wine that I like.
I really enjoyed it last night and I was
actually going to order a whiskey but I
always said the referee.
The waiter forgot to come back and asked
me at that point I was just like fuck
this I'm just going to stay with the wine
and then tonight my family took me out
for Father's Day and they had one whisky
and I oh man I got a fucking good one
right.
I got a really good 28 years old and then
I went outside to return a phone call
and I'd set the glass down I came back
and one of my red lines had bumped the
table and said they knocked a little bit
out and I didn't think there was that
much and then I looked down there was
this big puddle of it. I was like fuck.
That was 28 years old.
I mean the back of my head I was like
Oh that's good because I'm trying not to
drink anyways but I was 28 years
old the shit poured in a glass.
I sipped it and then somebody came by.
Boom hit the table.
And then there was a puddle of it.
He spent 20 years in a fuckin barrel to
be spilt on the floor and then cleaned
up with a rag.
That's a travesty.
I felt my liver crack but it was good
because then I had the perfect amount of
booze and I was fine.
So I don't know.
I know you guys were in a you know
collecting a little chippy poos there.
You know just five days sober you
know give you a little cookie.
Got you down there.
There's no way even if I was like a full
on fucking algae like I'm in Tripoli of
alcoholism I never got called up to
the big show I'm basically like Kevin
Costner in bull durham except I'm drinking
that would annoy me.
Going to AA and give me my stupid chip
like that's what I'm like I'm supposed to
be fuckin chasing these things I
get too much of a contrarian in me.
That's the new word for cunt by the way.
Yeah I'm a bit of a canary a canary
a contrarian a bit of a contrary.
Yeah.
You you're you're difficult.
You're a cunt. You know.
Your fucking pain in the ass.
You're the kind of guy off
the fucking jet went down.
You're the fucking guy you're
the guy that would get us killed.
We'd all be fucking sick
now if we survive. Go ahead.
You know what I say we go over this ridge.
Everybody agree with yeah.
And is why I won't go to turbo this rich.
Well what do you fucking go over
there buddy. Get mauled by a bobcat.
Well wait feet are
slowly dying in the air.
There there's a new nourishment for
the rest of this fucking walk down this
snowy god forsaken tundra.
Anyway sorry.
The fuck my topic and so.
So we go to the car show.
None of the fucking restaurants are open
fuck the dads. It's like food trucks.
Nobody gives a you know what's
funny though. I didn't give a shit.
My wife was upset.
Are we don't of these places are open.
She's like you are right with us again.
I don't give a shit. I don't give a shit.
You know I really don't.
I am I am I am the way I'm wired like
a guy I walked around I looked at some
shiny cars I'm happy it's hot as shit
let's get back in the car go home.
I'm fine. Completely fine. Brunch.
That's that's some you shit
turning this whole fucking thing into a
whole day. Yeah. Father's Day lead it.
I had to buy the perfect
Father's Day and then
I say I started my day
with fuckin no fun.
Billy I can wake up now
like super early and
I finally have a little
drum space about 20 ways.
A little a little Jesus Christ came
to tuck a little ways away for like 20
minutes away from my house.
I got a little rehearsal studio right.
You can just rent them.
And I got the smallest fucking one I could
buy stretch out I can touch the walls
on all sides and I got this little fuckin
that little sonar kit that I bought
the martini kit 16 inch based bass drum
which cracks me up because I was playing
that giant Bynum one that had
a 26 inch fuckin bass drum.
And I'm trying to you know.
Just go in a completely
different direction after
all of these goddamn years of
just fucking trying to ape everything
that he did and I just I it just hit me
one fucking day I told you what if one
day I just sat there and he said What is
this fucking guy came back to life and
he came walking into my house I keep
saying this on the podcast right.
And I was just like hey hey
man John Bonham Holy shit.
I'm a big fan of yours come
in and look at my drum kit.
I had his exact drum kit right
down to the Rogers high hat.
He would have looked that he would have
slowly backed out of the fucking room.
And what was funny is now I'm going down
this whole fucking rabbit hole you know
I'm listening to Pantera and fucking
Primus and Miles Davis figure that one out
listening to all his fucking great
drummers from Philly Joe Tony Williams to
fucking Jack D and I just
listen to these fucking geniuses
and trying to get something else in my
fucking head and through reading up on
Tony Williams I went down this fucking
rabbit hole full of I don't know how many
hours on the Internet just trying to
have all these tracks I was listening to
and trying to see if I could.
There's so many tracks where Tony is
just killing it live and they just won't
show him.
It's so fucking annoying that we show
showing miles of coal train of fucking
nicotine in political train miles of
fuckin was it shorter that he played with.
I don't know if they're
always showing those guys yes.
It's like if everybody else stops
playing they'll finally fucking show him.
It's annoying but you know typical
they never show the drummer.
That's why I love the Romantics.
When I was a kid and what I like about
you came out and I finally got the
drummer was singing.
The drummer sang then there would be
on a hotel california with Don Henley.
You'd see the drummer
the whole fuckin time.
Other than that you were shit out of luck.
So anyways I ended up
when you read about Tony that leads
to Billy carbon which leads to fucking
eventually
you know I don't know Vinny called Uta
and Steve Smith and all these fucking
guys and then they start talking about
the guys they listen to and then you go
back around again.
It's amazing.
So I end up finding this
quote that really made me
feel good about getting rid
of the drum kit that I did.
Cause sometimes I think I and I always
wanted that Kit and I finally fucking had
it.
And then I just always think Yeah and you
sat down and played it and you sounded
like you.
So it was too fucking big for you and
you have all these other ideas why don't
you go pursue those and I just stumbled
on this quote by Vinnie calling you to
write.
That's actually transcends playing drums
you can apply this to anything he says.
This is what he was trying
to find his own style.
He said I went through periods where
I tried to imitate Tony and Billy.
That's Tony Williams a Billy cop.
He goes by eventually
realized how dangerous it was
basically trying to imitate
those guys.
He goes I began to ask
myself what am I saying.
I wasn't saying anything.
It had been said before and
that a reason for being said.
But I didn't have a reason.
I wasn't making a statement.
I was just repeating it like a parrot
by imitating and copying someone else.
A person becomes a parrot.
I saw the trap and I knew as great as
those guys were and still are that I had
to find my own voice and
I was like God damn it.
Look at that.
That applies to stand up comedy that
applies to fucking washing cars.
Do you want to be one of the greats.
You know how many times
can you watch Mr me argue.
Do the wax on wax off before you're going
to fucking break out of then come up
with a new way to do it right.
I don't want to tell you I'm just happy
that I got this place so I wake up now
because
you know the way my daughter sleeps she
sleeps in these four hour chunks so she
finally falls asleep you know around 2:00
in the morning after she slept for my
you know eight to 12 then she'll be up
for an hour and a half or some shit and
then she sleeps till like 7 my wife
feeds her and then she goes back to sleep
again until 10:00. So that window
right there from seven to 10.
Now I've just been jumping in the car
drive 20 minutes down the street nobody's
up there's no musicians over that place
you know they're just getting done doing
blow they're going home you know they're
like 8:00 in the fucking morning and I
get to play for like a nice solid hour
having the time of my fucking life.
I don't know why I didn't do this for
myself years ago and it never dawned on me
to do it.
I was always trying to play him in the
fucking house and trying to find quiet
ways to do it because he was kidding.
Drums are fucking annoying other
unless you're the person playing him.
So I finally got this place and um I'm
beyond psych so we'll see we'll see what
this little kid leaves to me
but I know whatever I'm just
saying it was a great Father's Day.
So we went out tonight and then got
a nice framed picture of me hold my
beautiful daughter and I could not be
having my arms around her anymore and she
looks content is how it was an instant
classic of kissing her on the cheek and I
got it framed and looking at right now
sitting on my desk I'm fucking psyched.
So Happy Father's Day Father's
Day to all the fathers out there.
You know if you used to play drums you
want to play him again go get one of
those.
Get that fucking that Quest Love little
break beats set go find some fucking
studio space.
Cause you're like one twenty five
twenty bucks a month who gives a fuck
you know go get it go down there bring
your fucking you know or find a studio
space like you know where I used to play
I never used to say they said he wanted
but he bugged me down there.
The best place that I
found out here in L.A.
You don't have time to get a drum kit
knowledge shit but if you just want to go
play someplace is Cascade studios down
on Santa Monica just east of Highland
it's the shit it's fucking clean the
drunk it's a great and it was the first
class place and I went to a bunch of
places that was the best place that I've
found so free plug there.
And speaking of that.
Speaking and oh by the way everybody
keeps telling me to watch the fucking
Lakers sceptics documentary thing that
they got on ESPN so I have to check that
out but before I do that.
Before I do that if I get fucked up to
get the podcast that podcast I fucked up
the password
you know complex these things have to be
now you know I you know I hate when you
fucking put a nice easy one in and then
they just say to you like oh yeah that's
not that's not good enough
it's not fucking good enough
it's like well why don't
I determine that why are you acting like
I'm in the Pentagon I don't give a fuck
you know what I mean.
Oh you know it's hilarious too now
I gotta I'm out of my Bonham phase
I still play to some Zeppelin today I'm
like a lady when I was over there but
somebody show me his fucking remember
that car and the song remains the same.
That crazy look and I don't know who
made it forward or some shit that he had
that oh that crazy paintings
and stuff like that.
You know you always wonder what happened
to that shit if somebody bought it and
then somebody else bought
it and now it's up for sale.
It's like two hundred and fifty fucking
grand you know he's gonna buy that
thing.
I'm on a Jimmer say.
The Colts.
I think that guy's gonna end up having.
Like the equivalent of
Jay Leno's car collection.
He's gonna have that
with musical artifacts.
I mean the guy's getting to the point
where he can kind of fuck with the Rock
and Roll Hall of Fame.
He's got like a prince guitar.
He's got Jerry Garcia's guitar.
They had John Bonham Carr.
I mean that really adds to the collection.
Then you put your fuckin Prince's guitars
and all this Charlie Parker saxophone
whatever the fuck else
that guy owns in the back
yes some hookers come over he starts
doing blow whatever the fuck it is he does
it make it could be a good time.
No. Anyways let's let's
read some advertising here.
Upside down.
Boy you turn me all right upside there's
a better way round it round your turn.
I mean but without one that's all that's
obscure the key is take the upside down
you turn me the dirt upside there's a
better way for you to buy business travel
it's called upside down every time you
buy a trip at upside you'll save your
company a ton of money and they give you
an amazon gift card worth hundreds of
dollars.
Upsides able to do this because they
bundle your flights and hotel together for
one low price bundled saving
bundled prices saves money.
Well what the hell do I still get a gift
card worth hundreds of dollars maybe if
you get a bundle and
it's going to save money.
I'm going to come out around 3 and it
all is that he gonna give me to win it
back. This is like the
greatest fucking deal ever.
If you're a frequent business traveler
your company saves a ton of money and you
could get thousands a year in gift
cards just for buying your air and hotel
together upside.
Plus you still get all your miles if
you're shopping for business travel travel
you be crazy not to
check out upside dot.com.
Oh I get this this is if you're buying
like business tickets selling it is
business class.
It takes just three minutes to see how
much you can save by buying your flights
and hotel together for one low price.
And right now when you use my name Barbie
you are you're guaranteed to get at
least one hundred dollar Amazon at least
a one hundred dollar Amazon gift card
for your first trip. It probably
depends on how much the ticket is.
I would guess that's my name.
Barbie you are to get at least a one
hundred dollar Amazon gift card for free.
Save Big on travel and get a big gift
card every trip I love upside dot.com
evidently even though I've
never used it upside dot.com.
Minimum purchase required see site for
complete details I should start fucking
using that
but then I need you know you give me an
amazon card and then I've got to go out
and buy shit.
I'm trying to get shit out of my
fucking house I know I did I read it.
I'll give it to somebody else see you
go you buy shit you drown in your own
fucking artifacts whatever
the hell it is you're buying.
A black tux everybody black tux.
There's only so many opportunities in
life to wear a tuxedo so when you're big
day or special event why
and what are the days
you don't get married go into a prom.
You somehow know the mayor and he's
fucking got something going on you know.
What else did you wear when you're
on trial. Would be fucking hilarious.
Wear a tuxedo.
It's like he's shown respect and saying
you're a little crazy Sunni if they
convict you can be like Hey.
The guy is out of his fucking mind
who is a taxi who wears a tuxedo.
There's so many you hate when you when
your big day special event comes rolls
around this spring or summer look just
as great as you feel with suits from
black tux dot com with high quality
rental suits and tuxedos delivered to your
doorstep the black tux
gives you a new way to rent.
Plus with their free home try on you
can see the fit and feel the quality of
your suit months before your event.
And the best part is it's
completely done online.
The blue tux dot com lets you create
your look and choose from tons of styles
stylists selected outfits suits like
these usually retail retail for twelve
hundred dollars. But at the black tux
they start at just ninety five dollars.
If you have any questions or issues in
which you issue in their expert customer
care team has your back
every step of the way.
After ordering your suit will
arrive 14 days before your event.
Why do I blow off commas after ordering
your suit will arrive 14 days before
your event period. If anything else
if anything is less than perfect.
The black tux was the black tux.
We'll send you a free replacement right
away when your events over just drop
your rental back in the mail.
He's wanted up in the fucking box.
Shipping is free both ways.
How easy is that stand out your friend.
Just thinking of all the stains on the
tuxedo. Have a fuckin has met suit on
dude if you have a tuxedo at some
point that night your dicks coming out.
That's just a fact. Stand out at your
event for the right reason with the black.
Black tux to get twenty dollars off your
purchase visit the black tux dot com
slash br.
That's the black talk sitcom slash burn
for twenty dollars off your purchase two
more reads guys hang in
there hang the fuck in there.
I was bored with my reading as you are.
Legal Zoom
in order to successfully
run your business. Attention
to detail is so critical.
One contract slip up.
Jesus or a legal misunderstanding.
I didn't do it can really set you back.
Fortunately there's legal zone zone yet
you may already know that over a million
Americans have used legal zoom to start
their business but legal zoom services
go well beyond business formation.
They built a nationwide network
of independent attorneys
who could provide legal
answers to day to day questions you have
about your business because let's face
it.
Things like trademarks employment laws
and lease agreements can get pretty
complicated.
That's such a nice way of saying you're
too scatterbrained to want to deal with
this shit.
Let us handle it so don't waste your
valuable time trying to wrap your head
around all the fine print.
Use legal zoom for that so they can
focus so you can focus on growing your
business instead.
You'll get the legal help you need without
being billed by the hour since legal
zoom isn't a law.
I've never understood that sentence.
Get legal advice from a fuckin
place it isn't a law firm.
Go to legal zoom dot com today and be
sure to enter the enter code bar and the
referral box for special savings.
Only a legal zoom dot com.
Lastly but not lately Dollar
Shave Club do Dollar Shave Club.
Is this marriage choice. You'll get
your great shave at a great price.
Conveniently delivered
right to your deal where.
You no longer have to
schlep to this store.
To buy a cheap disposable razor that
gives you a cheap shave or spend a fortune
on razors with gimmicky
shaving technology. You don't
fucking need. All right.
When you use your Dollar Shave Club's
Executive razor with it can cab easy.
The blade gently glides across your balls
giving you a smooth sheen on your face.
Dr. carver shave butter is transparent
for the more prices precise shave helps
present ingrown hairs and fights
razor bumps. There you go.
They handle all the way to white to black
people there make the smarter choice
by joining Dollar Shave
Club for a limited time.
New members can get their first month
of the executive razor with a tube of
their doctor Carver's easy Shea but
for only five dollars with free shipping
after that raises it just a few bucks a
month. That's a 15 dollar
value for only five bucks.
There are no hidden fees and no
commitments cancel anytime you like.
You can only get this offer exclusively
at Dollar Shave Club dot com slash br.
That's Dollar Shave Club dot com slash
birth think fuck and Christ that's over
over.
All right.
So anyways I guess I really
fucking overextended myself.
This month I said yes to way
too much shit and for July.
My answer is gonna be No.
I don't give a fuck when anybody asked me.
No I believe no I'm not doing it.
I'm not fucking doing it. I. I got.
I'm on the road again.
Boom boom boom boom.
I'm doing the roast of David
or TS this week Thursday.
And you know I've got to
figure out I don't do that.
I'm not saying this guy walk a walk.
But this bubble bobble yada yada yada.
You know those fuckin roast jokes for
summarizing the format of roast jokes is
still from the 1950s.
I don't understand why that is.
I have to figure out how to do this shit.
So-and-so is here you know.
Last time I saw I had like dad and a
fucking wagon wheel well I well you know
they still use that except the young guys.
Now they all say AIDS and cunt and fuck
and it just it's just so over the top.
You know 9/11 it's always like I gotta
figure out how the fuck to do this and I
only have four days to do it.
And of course I'm busy as shit
so I don't know what to do here.
So but this is the last thing if I just
get past this which I will either by
doing a good job a mediocre job
or eating my fucking balls on it.
The bottom line is it's over.
You know it's it's a 12 minute spot.
I just have to get if I get past this
fucking roast the rest of I'm gonna eat
the rest of my year.
It's downhill.
Billy no fun is saying no to everything.
What do you what what is it.
I can't make it now.
Can't do it.
Nah nah nah not gonna throw it at me like
that fuckin buzzard way back a little
thought but they put up a lowball put him
in that bashful buzzard on Bugs Bunny.
No.
The whole market though.
That's gonna be me.
I have to start fucking doing that because
yeah it's not good. It's just too much
shit. And I am I'm again now with the kid.
I'm fuckin I'm exhausted.
It's 9 22 at night and I was ready
for bed two fucking hours ago.
It's just my cutie pie doesn't
fall asleep till about 9:00
and you know what's great about no
booze you sleep like a fuckin baby.
I mean booze will put you to sleep but
the next morning you wake up and you're
just like you know
you wake up you feel you
should be tied to a chair.
And there's some guy just waiting
for you to come around to continue
interrogating you by punching you in
the head and then you realize like now I
punched myself in the head
with all those fuckin drinks.
So I'm actually really enjoying it
despite the fact that I drank the last two
nights. I have one tonight and half
of it's spilt on the fucking ground.
All right.
Fucking judge me.
All right I decide. I'm in my own AA
okay. I still earned a chip today.
I just feel like for me having
my own AA is a good thing.
Speaking of for me in reality show stars
you're not going to fucking believe who
I think was at that car show today.
We're walking around we're looking at
Dave it's fucking this two to a Cadillac
that I swear to God was like it
was like two town cars put together
incredible fucking car.
Gigantic Oh my God I saw this one Jaguar
you know the one that the early that
one of their had in the 60s
with the long fucking Hood
not the one from the 50s that Sinatra
had that one the James Bond era one you
know the one and the patched back
open like a fuckin regular door.
This guy showing it off he's got the back
door open and then the hood opens like
the reverse way you know
from the windshield out
looks cool as shit and then I
look in there he's got like some small
box small block Chevy engine in there
you know I don't know if that's what you
want to fucking do I don't know why you
would do that.
Anyways I
walk around looking at those cars and
all of a sudden there's there's these
people on like they're giving out awards
to cars and shit and there's these
listeners this person on the microphone
going I think that's Caitlyn Jenner I
think Caitlyn Jenner's hand I was like
no fucking way I gotta go seek I gotta go
see Katie I gotta go see when
by the time we got there.
I'm not even sure if I was
but like has said that Bruce
it gets confusing she sees she
said she's really into cars
so I got confused saying like ah it was
was he not into it and then can that
happen.
Do your hobbies change then I know what
she was saying like no he was into him
he's always been into him
and now he's become Caitlyn
days wants it transferred
what's the fucking word you're
supposed to say transitioned
helicopter November 1 5 3 Sierra hotel
on with you information Bravo requesting
token transition through transition
to you know being Caitlyn but
the hobbies stay the same.
There you go.
Who would know that I would think
you'd take up some other hobbies right.
Maybe you wouldn't
I got to look this up.
This is fucking weird because I know
you take hormones and stuff right.
So does that make it any other shit.
It's fine it's fascinating you know and
you know it's funny is they're going to
keep doing the same way they're doing
the plastic surgery where you know it's
gonna keep looking better and better
and better. You know what I mean.
Same way you know everything keeps getting
better and better and better except
for the fucking environment you know.
Oh by the way I did a fuckin benefit the
other night and flea was in the crowd.
I can't fucking believe I didn't give him
a shout out for giving a shit about BS.
That was one of the few positive things
I saw about the environment last year
was that fleas somehow got it you know
fleas of the fucking bees are dying off
and fleas shows up like a goddamn hero
and it gets into these beekeepers stuff.
He's got the whole suit and everything
I saw this whole article on it.
Any he sees hooking up like a little
like there was like ten thousand of them
hanging out in his backyard.
You know.
What's funny is that's one of those
things your neighbors would be annoyed at
because they don't understand
photosynthesis I don't
know where that fuckin word
came from but I literally I think I I
think I used it correctly this and that
when the bees go from flower to flower
and stuff gets on their cute little feet
you know that cute little beefy you know.
And then they pollinate
shit inadvertently.
They're out there running errands
for the queen. Right. The Queen Bee.
The fuck was I talking about.
Oh my God look this shit up.
When you
transition
to your hobbies.
Change fucking list. Am I gonna
get put on looking this shit up.
Come on man don't do this to me.
Come on internet.
Come on internet can you fucking work
for once in your life you fucking cunt.
Can you believe someone who can't even
get Internet in his whole house is
talking about having a chauffeur. I mean
how fucking first world country is that.
Habit change is easy when
people move into a house.
For strategies to change your habits.
Well they're not specific enough.
This has to be I have to be wrong.
You transition to a woman
do your hobbies change
thirteen ways to master the transition
from college to the real world.
Habit Change is easier.
How to successfully transition your diet.
Nerd fitness health in your 40s.
You know what I search to twice I guess.
So Bruce was into it. Now Bruce is
Caitlin Caitlin's like you know.
Good on you Bruce way to get those
fuckin cars because I'm still digging a
that's fucking amazing.
You know I hope someone I
know fucking transitions.
I want to see that whole goddamn thing.
You know
someone's got it something it's
it's gotta be something all right.
Does your preference a color change if
you'd taken hormones like your fucking
would like the chemicals right.
Is it it fucking amazing how I just
refuse to read about shit and I just
continue to ask questions
while answering them.
But this is how I come to conclusions
and then I can somehow legally get on
stage with the microphone
and do a fucking podcast.
I can't imagine how many people who used
to be men and are now women are just
slapping their female for head their
transition for head right now listening to
me as I'm talking of I apologize to
anybody out there transitioning I don't
fucking mind what I think that
you because she said she's really into
cars doesn't take a night to trip me up
that's all I'm saying.
All right let's read some shit here.
Right.
Mute Math and cold bear
Hey Billy boom bap.
But boom boom back.
Thanks for putting me onto mute math.
Oh my God they're fucking
amazing fucking incredible band.
They've got a brand new album out.
Whatever you could say they got some
brand new shit that you can download
through the fucking air and
capture it on your device.
Share it with your friends.
Man
this guy says I've seen the name before
but never listened and they are all caps
fucking dope.
Just bought a ticket to see
them on their tour in September.
Dude you are not going to be disappointed
they are fucking as good as their band.
Their albums are their fucking
incredible life. Fucking incredible band.
And then he said to me.
Told me to check out these bands it
says check out Big Data in Portugal.
I don't understand this next
sentence it says the man karma.
I think you might dig them. Is the
man also a band. I'll look it up.
All right.
If my internet hasn't shut down after
that last stupid fucking search keep
drumming and make Stephen keep drumming
and making Stephen Colbert uncomfortable.
Oh I did the Stephen Colbert
show last Thursday aired Friday.
I wasn't making him uncomfortable. He
enjoyed it. I had a great time with him.
He's a.
I met him briefly one time at some
benefit but he's a really good dude it was
fucking amazing to go back and do that
show because that's where Letterman used
to tape and it's still
fucking ice cold in there.
It's still roughly like the same setup
and it's just weird because Cobain's desk
is over where the band is and
I talk to him you know
during the break I go out.
I was just crazy being over here.
You know I did stand up on Letterman
like 4 5 times and this is where I always
look over and Felicia and Paul Schaefer
Anton Fig all the whole band was over
there and now the desk is here and he
said that he asked Letterman where he
should put the desk and Letterman said
on the right side saying that he always
wanted to sit over there
but Johnny sat over there.
So out of respect he
sat on the other side.
That's how much you know the level of
respect that wasn't just amazing story.
The level of respect that Letterman
had for Carson and why wouldn't you.
That guy's the king of it all.
But Letterman was the Carson
of my generation all right.
Phelps versus the shark.
Bill I just listened to
your Monday morning your
Thursday afternoon just before
Monday podcast and enjoyed your rant.
About the upcoming fight
between McGregor and Mayweather.
It's not wasn't a rant wasn't a rant.
I just was discussing the fucking subject
if I was screaming and yelling ranting
and raving that is a fucking rant.
You know I'm going to look up
rant about probably got wrong
wrong about you know if you
transition your fucking habits change.
Why the fuck would I be wrong
about this rant definition.
Come on. Somehow I got to rant now
what the fuck is that. No rant.
You cunt.
Come on
definition
OK.
Rant definition.
Speak or shout at length
in a wild impassioned way.
Yes.
She was still ranting on the.
I don't know.
Well I think this just goes back to me
being from Massachusetts and my ideas of
of yelling and fucking being out of
control are just different than everybody
else's. But you go on to say a rant
that finally fine whatever yeah.
I just don't I fucking hate most
about that McGregor Mayweather fight.
Aside from the fact that McGregor
is only going to be allowed to box
that guy is a fucking Swiss Army Knife
to death and they only let him take out
the spoiled you know
you fucking annoys the shit out of me
about that fight as I know I'm going to
order it.
I know I'm going to wondering
how do you lay off that.
Once I found out it's going to be 100
bucks I thought it would be like 20 bucks
I thought they were both making a hundred
million I guess Mayweather makes a
hundred million McGregor makes twenty
million for whatever fucking reason.
How fucked up is that.
I think the guy that isn't you know if
they were doing the fact that McGregor
isn't allowed to do what the fuck you
know we could do which is put Mayweather
right on his back and the thing
would be over in 30 fucking seconds.
He should be getting 100 million.
This is a walk in the park for Mayweather.
This is his fuckin strength
and never went the other way.
McGregor was allowed to use all of his
fucking fighting skills then Mayweather
should get the hundred million.
This is classic Mayweather.
This guy's a fucking genius.
He's getting it entirely his way and
he's making 80 million dollars more than
this other fucking guy.
Anyways he goes did you see that Michael
Phelps is going to raise a great white
shark for some discovery channel thing.
I fucking refused. That's a joke right.
That has to be a joke.
Do I have to look this up.
I thought you might like that one.
That's.
That is fucking ridiculous.
All right I can look it up.
What. Dude even if the shark
was full I mean that's.
This is like the Mayweather fucking
McGregor fight. This is what he does.
Meet Phelps swims but he also does
other shit he goes to restaurants.
You know what I mean.
He hits a bong every once in a while.
What the fuck does a shark do.
That's all it does. There's no
fucking way. There's no selfies.
Oh my God it came. No. Phelps first shark.
This can't be fuckin real
Michael Phelps to race a
great race against a great
white shark in shark weeks.
Phelps first shark.
Jesus Christ of average has been
on the fucking Wheaties box.
Not making enough money doing that.
Michael Phelps isn't done swimming yet
the twenty three time twenty three time
Olympic gold medalist this
guy is twenty three gold five.
You know what this guy wants to race
as you know we get. Course he does.
He's done with human beings.
I think a shark is a good tune up
fight when you go into the ocean.
I think that's why I don't know who put
this together. Maybe it was Mayweather.
He said he always picks the
perfect fuckin opponent.
You go in there gets a great
white shark in Artemis there.
They're not known for this speed are they
always dolphins zipping around.
It's always the shit that they have to
fucking catch that's fast rate than the
slowest thing gets cut by twenty three
time Olympic gold medalists will compete
in the most adrenaline filled race yet
when he swims against a great white shark
for its discovery Channel's Shark Week.
All right so how do I handicap this.
Are they starting in the water is the
shark gonna get up on that fuckin block to
wait for the whistle.
We got a false start.
We got a false
we're having difficulty explaining to the
shark what the fucking whistle is he's
just so freaked out that he's out
of his natural atmosphere here
in Phelps first shark great gold verse
great white is what they're calling this
the retired athlete will take on
the ocean's most efficient predator
in a competition of speed.
Jesus Christ can you imagine.
Who is Nike putting up the swim
goggles for the fucking shark.
All right I guess.
Phelps tweeted something I was able to
do something that I had always wanted to
do.
Being a cage and dive
with great white sharks
you see Mary's got a kid now
give him first birthday party.
Happy Father's Day to him.
What kind of a dad he's got. You know
what. He's got all that gold you know.
You know it's funny.
The dollar the entire U.S. economy
could collapse and he's gonna be fine.
He's got twenty three gold medals you
just melt those fucking thing down.
You make a little nickel sized coins
that guy's in subs for the rest of his
fucking life.
Phelps great white race isn't
the only shark week special.
He'll be appearing in the
father of one will also.
I don't give a fuck about what he's doing.
I.
Together the trio will dispel myths
and misconceptions and teach Phelps the
proper way to get up close and personal
with hammerheads and great whites
OK you know what's funny about
fucking the Discovery Channel.
After all these years of being the
champions the absolute champions of mis
information about sharks you'd always
watch their things on the sharks
you'd always watch these
things on the sharks and
while you watch the program
they'd always say all this.
You know these things are being hunted
down there aren't misunderstood.
Blah blah blah.
But when you watch the fucking advertising
for that week shark week it was
always there was like another Jaws
movie was coming out was really bad.
So now I guess they're finally feeling
guilty and maybe some younger people came
in on the Discovery Channel
and they've finally done.
Shitting on sharks.
So where they're waiting and they've
been a fucking saltwater pool
if they're in a pool.
I like Phelps for the simple fact that I
have a feeling that the sharks gonna go
out of its lane and be disqualified and
at the very least the shark can't do
that little somersault flip at
the end of the fucking pool.
Jesus Christ is this this is what the
world is the world of sport is becoming I
don't know back in the days to have
those fucking fat bald guys strongman
they're always bald right.
Some lifting weights back in the day you
know you went bald there would always
be pullin trains with their teeth and shit
all right first time listening hey Bill
first time listening to your podcast.
My husband and I came to L.A. for the
Rose Bowl last year and saw you stand up.
We love it. Thank you.
Thanks for taking so much.
Thanks so much for talking in
detail about jazz and sports.
I think this show this think this shows
a lot of respect for your audience.
We like cool shit obviously we like
to stand up don't be afraid to go into
technical details about whatever.
It's interesting.
Any who happy podcasting.
Well all right.
There's two people that are enjoying it.
I think I talked about it a little bit.
I downloaded all of this
fucking Miles Davis shit.
I am like I was a huge
Miles Davis fan like.
In the early 90s and my favorite album
was in a Silent Way and I read his
autobiography.
I got like fucking.
I mean I had all his shit on cassette
tapes. I even got like on the corner.
Which he talks about in his book how when
Herbie Hancock came out with chameleon
like that's what he was trying to do
that head on jazz album but you know he
blamed the record labels saying that
they fucked up the promotion of it
but I got into all of that shit and then
I moved to New York and I
stopped playing drums because
I was living in a walk through
fucking bedroom apartment.
I just drums it too goddamn loud I didn't
play for like five six years and then
I started back up again.
So I started in 88 and I've been
like a five year break in there so
I've been playing about 19 years.
That is what it is.
I don't what the fuck it is.
But anyways Dave Brubeck jazz
stuff here we got more drunk shit.
Dear Billy backbeat not the exact error
you were asking for but Dave Brubeck's
band experimented with some crazy time
signatures starting in the early 60s look
for the album The Dave Brubeck
Quartet at Carnegie Hall.
I bought it when I was a music major
in college and it was a borderline
spiritual experience.
It's got songs in 11 for
aptly named eleven for.
Wait a minute eleven for now.
How the fuck does that work out.
Eleven for C just count that's when
you count that just up to eleven
all right.
So that's just basically it's like playing
three three bars of four and then you
just play one bar three four and you
just lop off that last bit right.
Five four take five nine eight.
Blue Rondo Alla Turk.
Not only are the songs great but the
audio quality is impressive for the time
period.
Every once in a while you can even hear
Dave or another member of the band blurt
out a cool jazzy during a solo.
It really immerses you in the time
period and culture. All right.
You know this is a classic.
I'm going to download this and listen
to this with some really nice headphones
in the dark.
You probably wish that I did some drugs.
If you listened to a check out to track
Castilian drums at the four minute mark.
There's a drum solo where he turns the
snare off and does some really cool and
creative stuff with his hands
and it sticks on the snare.
If you look at Joe Morello shit where
he's playing with his hands and stuff and
then watch John Bonham playing with his
fucking hands I'm sure he Morello wasn't
the first the only guy to do it but
there's just a couple of things where he's
hit with the back of his hand and shit
and you see Bonham do that but then
there's also like.
Like YouTube and all that shit did
not exist when Bonham was coming up so
he was over in England.
The odds of him checking that out and
actually seeing it is so fucking I don't
know how people were able to.
You definitely listened
to everything you could.
But to actually get to watch all of em
was fucking it's when something something
came on the TV you just fucking
sat there and watched it.
There was no hit and pause there's
no all there's gonna be a rerun.
If you missed it you fucking missed it.
Anyways this guy says thanks and go fuck
yourself with that shiny new high head
stand. Jesus Christ. All right.
Join in the army.
Hey Nia if you want to come
in there's a question for you.
Yeah.
Grab a grab a mike.
Bring in the taking.
Grab a mike bring in the
take and grab a mike.
La la la la la.
Get your ass in here and do the podcast.
Bye bye.
Where are you.
Oh you're coming.
It's hot as hell and you wonder why
I don't open a window. I don't know.
Okay. Can you can you. There's
a microphone over there.
Can you in the closeted area.
Oh Jesus she's.
She's a beauty.
Well I can't do a podcast and
hold the kid at the same time.
Jesus Christ where am I multitasking.
Hey buddy.
Mike up on on top of
the fucking thing there.
On top of that that thing straight ahead.
She's got it.
Please don't tip over my computer.
Don't tip it over. All
right. This is perilous.
I'm holding her and there's a computer
here. She's gonna knock it over.
She's gonna knock it over.
What's up Kutty pie.
What's up Kutty. All
right. Plug it in there.
Plug it in plug it in and here we go.
Ladies and gentlemen coming back to the
podcast I don't need to put the screen.
You don't need put a windscreen
on any of the windows open.
Can you grab your beautiful
daughter here please please.
You crazy. I know I know. I know. I know.
All right. Here's a question for you.
How did you pull the map up.
All right. Here's your question.
All right.
You ready.
Dancing wedding.
Hey there billy back freckle
my girlfriend and myself are attending
a wedding for our good friends.
Two gay fellas. It's a very
progressive podcast by the way.
That you're doing.
Yes.
Because I already brought up Caitlyn
Jenner and I learned something today when
you kind of freak me out when you said
like oh she's really into cars why did I
freak you out.
Because I know I had to do the math in
my head was like was Bruce not into cars.
Then I was like No way I've ever read the
Sports Illustrated and Porsches and he
was a pilot and all that shit right.
Mm hmm.
Does his pilot's license must transfer
over. You got to change the name.
How far out crazy is that then you got
to go down there be like listen I'm this
guy now I'm sure it's it's every everyone
knows that Caitlyn Jenner is Brown
right.
So if you're not ready
what if you're not famous.
Yeah if you're not famous you probably
got to do that some. Yeah and I do.
I am.
I am good.
You know I'm going to get you for Mother's
Day next year speaking into a mike
class.
Sorry.
All right.
So here it is.
By the way so I google that when you
transition do your habits change and
nothing came up.
So I guess it does.
Okay.
What's the goal you want to take one
little thing would be kind of like oh shit
now I'm into this.
If you take him like hormones and stuff
like when some change your favorite
color would change.
I don't think so.
It doesn't affects your brain right.
Why aren't you allowed to ask questions
about this shit is be like Oh my God
what are you a fucking Trump supporter.
I'm really excited to go to this wedding.
He's saying OK these two gay guys are
getting married grant to gay fellas as he
says. I'm really excited to go minus
the fact that they are dancing fools.
Could they be more stereotypical.
My girl and that whole group
will be dancing the night
away. Well it's a wedding.
Yeah.
Do you not want to do this.
No I'm just trying to. I'm I.
I shouldn't wait to hear the
question fully. Please proceed.
OK. You seem annoyed at any point you
need to walk out. I'm fine with it OK.
He says meet for me.
Says me for me or me I
just feel he says me.
I'm not a dancer.
Perhaps I shouldn't assume but I'm
assuming that you're no dancer yourself.
Evidently he has not seen Daddy's home.
He writes
I'm the worst.
I'm your standard pasty white guy who
doesn't really dance. I don't like it.
I don't really understand it.
It's just you don't understand.
Just seems goofy to me.
I totally line up with this guy.
I have an appreciation for your NEW DAY.
You danced at the wedding though you
danced at our wedding all night long.
I was drunk.
My girlfriend has expressed her dislike
with my opinion of dancing after a
couple of drinks.
Going as far as to tell me
it's a real disappointment.
I know that I don't enjoy dancing.
Oh I love how honest she is.
You know it's a real disappointment
in our four years together have you.
But I'm really this really disappointed
and I completely don't respect the fact
that you don't like something that I like.
Hey Nia Do you like hockey.
I'll know what I do. Could you
just play along. No I don't.
That's a real disappointment
in our four years together.
We've never really had any sort
of arguments other than that one.
Jesus Christ that's the only thing
you argue about how you're very lucky.
How often do you guys go marry this girl.
He goes I don't try and guilt her
into doing something she doesn't like.
So I get a little hot blooded
when she does it to me.
How long did she say
we danced to that one.
How blood was it that God gave
a fever of a hundred and three.
Oh baby.
Do you do more than dance right.
That's another white guy doesn't
want to dance. They do more to dance.
Can we get out of here the
weekend. Yeah. And Van herpes.
Well what do you think. What
do you think. Oh Ruby pubic.
Ruby Tuesday.
I don't stand my ground.
And what do I stand my ground and
what will most definitely become a
disagreement when I don't go flail around
like the non dancing whitey that I am
or do I sack up and do my best revolted
from Pulp Fiction and go attempt to cut
some rug even though I'll
be miserable the whole time.
Best to you your little one and in
season two of efforts for family has been
great. Thanks for the content
and go f yourself. All right
all right all right. So.
What do you say. Well as I'm
snorkeling said earlier it's a wedding.
So obviously there's gonna be dancing
whether they're gay guys or straight like
everybody dances at weddings. Let's
not. I don't know how he expect.
Like why would he think that
there wouldn't be dancing.
Maybe that's he had nothing do with the
gay guy. He just says he doesn't want to.
He just doesn't want to dance.
No one.
Can Dance.
Okay.
Oh that thing about me is the way that.
Well.
I don't know.
Listen girls that liked to dance like
guys that liked to dance with them.
That's just how it is.
You said the name of a new reality show.
If you don't go in there and do the YMCA
and the electric slide you can at least
do a couple of slow dances.
How about that.
Can you guy meet me outside. How about
that. Yes those cash meals at home. That
maybe that can be the compromise.
Listen I'm not going to
go up there YMCA and.
Break good come out.
Doo doo doo. This is not
a career. What's it like.
I don't know I'm saying what I saw.
None of those things would
get a beloved prince.
Do we have Prince at our wedding.
I don't want to stay focused.
Oh yes.
I think I think the compromise sir is
that you should give your lady a couple of
slow dances and also also.
Wait a minute.
It's one night.
It's not going to kill you to get
up there and like be goofy with her.
No one's watching you because I feel
like there's a little bit of you that's
like you don't like to dance because
you feel like you can't dance.
Nobody's looking at you.
Nobody's judging you.
It's one night out of your life.
Just be silly have fun with it and
definitely slow dance with her.
She'll really appreciate.
This is one of those times where.
Even though you don't like doing something
you do it for the person that you
love.
This is what it is my suggestion.
You're not going out dancing every single
Saturday would you. But with a wedding.
You said I'm a little distracted so I'm
sorry I can't put my mouth like you know
you want me to blow the damn microphone
not what you can do is Hello.
I'm thinking car. OK. I'll do
that. You're blowing the thing up.
I just this is what he should do.
He should go go there.
And have five quick drinks five five get
fucking hammered and then just go out
there and then just that's it.
You blackout drunk.
I don't think that doesn't get around
like a fish out of water. Yeah I don't.
Next day.
I don't know when you're hung over and
you're laying there and she's giving you
looks you just look at her and your best
Clint Eastwood voice and you just feel
like it was your idea.
You want me to dance.
These are the rules that would just sell
it say listen I'm going to dance my ass
off that night OK.
And I want you know how stupid I'm
going to feel I'm doing this for you.
However these are the rules.
You line up five shots.
I'm doing those
like Mr Blonde going through that bank.
Bam bam bam bam bam bam bam bam bam.
If you had made me go out on the fucking
dance floor I don't think you should
get a good Mr. Blonde that was all right.
I don't think you should be five
shots wasted. I think he should.
Would you accept three. I would take two
and see how it goes. Are you the worst.
Three give him three.
This gives us a major anxiety.
You think of all the stuff you
like to do. Right. Exactly. Yeah.
But I'm just saying well how about
this. Can he at least give her up. How.
Before he gets wasted. Can you just give
her a slow. Because we love slow dances.
They don't start with the slow dance.
I know you go out there and it's like
immediately like immediately get down on
it Get down on it.
Do do do do do do do do do do do do do
do the beat it is there was it just by
doing a neutron dates.
Someone stole my brand new Chevrolet.
Yeah.
At that point you've got to be like you
can be like fuck yeah you got to be.
You got to be five shots it it's one
night out of your life do it because your
lover chose and say I this
is my dancing for the year.
I loving you more night.
He's gotta be shitfaced.
Can you just let the guy get drunk.
I don't say this a lot. I don't says
Love is a white thing. What do you mean.
We don't do we don't dance the
way people dance all the time.
Fred Astaire. We did do it
professionally we just don't do it. I.
Read that one of those people on Dancing
With the Stars. That's it. I don't know.
All right here's another one for a
girl at jujitsu. A Billy bollocks.
So my dilemma is I'm 18 and I've
Oh my it's hot is friggin hell.
And when I enter the AC on. Because
what am I spot. I'll hit pause. Hang on.
All right. I'm back. Here we go.
So my dilemma is I'm 18 and I've just
finished the first my first year of
college a few months ago and
I've been hit in the gym.
Good for you as much as possible. Good
for you. And I've been going to jujitsu.
You're crushing it for the past couple
of months anyway first day going there I
noticed a girl in the beginner's class
with me and thought she was hot and she's
doing jujitsu.
This is this is nothing
but a great stuff so far.
So after a couple of weeks I work up
the nerve to talk to work. Good for you.
Turns out I went to school with a
younger brother something in common.
This is like all rainbows right now.
And I was also the youngest in my
years so I think she might be 19 or 20.
Jesus Christ this is just all aces.
On my computer screen keeps shutting down.
I don't know any way after training.
I don't know.
Anyway after training yesterday I
asked her I asked for her snapchat.
Is that the way millennials as four
digits. No. I never even said digits.
I'd be like What's your number.
I'll get a call yeah.
You like my Z Cadbury
cheese Daisy view carnage.
Dude it's a meat market.
Try not to curse in front of her even
though he's already done it 50 times here.
I don't know. I don't know. Anyway it's a
trip. And she gave it to me and after I.
Asked her for it I felt like a weight
had been lifted because I've never really
talked to that many girls let alone
get their Snapchat or whatever.
Good for you because I'm
incredibly reluctant and a
bit scared to talk to them.
Yeah. Pathetic. I know but I think
this girl's girlfriend material.
That's not pathetic.
Not just a fuck one time bitch.
That was pathetic. Yeah. He really
just made a left turn there.
That statement was pathetic.
He kind of built himself
up as the oh shucks guy.
Yeah. And then he now turned around
and said now he's a lady killer.
Yeah well I know what it is
what he's afraid of love.
Whatever. No no we'll see what you just
did. You just turned her off. All right.
I think I'm solo on this one
so Billy Boy what should I do.
How should I go about this.
How should I texture.
Any advice would be appropriate
appreciated. Love the podcast.
Wouldn't mind hearing for the lovely
knee is important too if possible.
Would love for you.
Could you just let a guy be a guy with me.
That's the equivalent you guys me like.
Well what does he do for a living.
How much does he make or what size
house could I get when I kick him out.
Is that the equivalent Bill.
Yes equivalence equivalent as well.
Nobody talks like that.
At least not in my circle.
Oh sorry.
Oh my God.
For me I feel I need a twist.
However your friend's dog would love for
you to not like play a gig in Ireland
sometime. Thanks. Go f yourself too.
I played a gig I played 3 last year I
went from Dublin up to Belfast and at the
Galway I had an isosceles
triangle of freckled fuckers
I performed two out there.
Are you trying to be a
bad ass with this whole.
Not a one time bitch fuck type of thing.
Like what what was that. What was that
little statement he threw in there.
Because that did really turn me off.
Why do you keep latching onto that. This
guy has all kinds of great qualities. 18.
He's he's he's one year into
college. OK. He's hitting the gym.
He's taking jujitsu.
He saw a beautiful woman he was
smitten by her and he's nervous OK.
He loves to use this locker room talk.
I just don't understand why he.
I just don't I don't build a wall around
why it has to be like categorizing
girls that he doesn't even know.
And so this is like the kind
of bitch you just fuck Woods.
And this is girlfriend material girl
fuckers. How about your neither.
How about you're not gonna get laid
and you're an asshole that won't have a
girlfriend. How about
that. How does that feel.
Meet me outside. How about it.
It gets really bad about me.
Yeah.
You guys do the same thing.
We're not talking about what you
guys do and what everybody else does.
I'm talking about this person
I wrote in this question. OK.
That's not that's not what
this conversation is about.
You know what everybody I'm a child.
I want her to feel my passion here.
OK. Now I owe her. I'm not. We are.
We're not discussing what
women do versus what men do.
We're talking about this particular
person who is like oh good for you.
You got her snapchat also.
Like Snapchat grow a pair and get her
number if you're really trying to like
come with it.
Like don't be lurking on her snapchat
so you can like jerk off to her like a
little selfie pics. I mean
with this person. I'm sorry.
I just you know what. I'm jealous
of this person. You know what.
I don't see that he's working out a
pretty little line that you threw in.
So I married his wife and he feeling
that type of way about it. So.
All right. Here's my. Well this
is reaction. Here's my advice.
What was what do you know something on.
I swear to God if you were a pitcher
right now I'm coming out and before I even
get to the mound I'm
taking you out of the game.
I don't even know what that means.
It means you get way too emotional you
lost your control and you're gonna you're
gonna kill somebody
else's girlfriend material.
Not just a one time you
know a bitch you fuck one.
This guy cannot run from the bullpen.
Quick enough.
You've completely lost your composure.
Hit the showers on this one.
All right.
How do you know what kind
of person she is. Oh boy.
Because you decided because you projected
what you want your fantasy because
she's not a real person to you right.
She's not a real person.
She's just someone you saw doing jujitsu
and is like Oh my God this is like my
dream girl. Not like those other girls
that you just like tossed to the side.
You don't even know her
you even care to know her.
You got her snapchat her snapchat really.
Grow a pair ask for the
number or stay the fuck away.
Don't be lurking online
like some kind of creep.
What is this person's name.
It was from Ireland Colin.
Mia.
Does Seamus.
Seamus O'Leary.
No shame this guy has no Seamus.
Sorry. Sorry. Derek listen. Yes.
Don't you hit. Did she guys have
like oh this guy's husband material.
Yes. Well all right then. So
why did you relax. All right.
Good Lord.
I did it.
I really got hot.
You got grumpy all right fine.
Yes this is that there
are days I eat your legs.
This guy you would not
want to be in relationship.
This is a guy that you just like bang
out a few times and don't ever see again.
Yes. What do you mean. You
bang out a few times now.
Right. You're right. Women do the
same thing. It's 100 percent true.
I think it just took 20 minutes to get
there. I don't know it just bugged me.
Of course it bugged me that I am being
a hypocrite because I've certainly had
those feelings toward certain guys.
So exactly.
And it's about time I start fucking
admitting that instead of acting like the
world owes you a round of drinks.
Here's a man.
He's found he's smitten with
this girl. He's afraid. Get out.
So he just needs a tooth coming in there.
Yes.
Well this is what I would say.
How should you go about this.
You have to do something that's
probably difficult at your age.
And I hate when older people say this
but you gotta figure out a way to be
yourself. You gotta
walk. You've said enough.
And I think you've said it. I'm sorry
Shane. I'm sorry I yelled at you.
I think you've said enough.
I think you dumped a whole bunch
of other stuff from other days.
Was it something I did. I don't know.
But this guy did not deserve that.
This is an 18 year old.
He just became a man.
Okay okay.
I overreacted a little.
He's a colleague go to college and he's
gonna want to defend his family back for
good eats right with his jujitsu.
I'm just saying if you were my
son I'd be like can you not.
Can you get off at me.
I'll write them off. Yeah.
You're a hypocrite you're a hypocrite.
But what I love about you is
you admit what a pig you are.
Like the rest of us.
Jesus Christ could you give
the kid some advice here.
What was the question.
He got our Snapshot.
He's nervous. He actually likes
this woman. What does he do.
He should just be himself just
say listen I got a admit like.
I saw you across the room and I
was a little mini heart attacks.
I really like you. I'd like to take you
out like you do. You gotta go on a stage.
Just asking. Yeah. You don't have to
just sit there and brood in the corner.
It's right. There's no reason
to feel what you do is you.
You fake with those ones you just gonna
bang somebody actually like you got to
be honest with them or else it's not
going to work. So just yeah okay.
This is getting what I say I want to
go. Okay cool. I think you will get.
I think you both need a nap. I'm sorry.
Yeah I know. I'm sorry about that.
It's all right. Hey we all
get it. Whatever his name is.
Yeah well you know his name is Vinny.
All right.
Okay.
Dancing at the wedding.
I already did that girly
jujitsu I already did that.
Did I answer all the questions.
Oh joining the army joining the army as
you can sail the seven seas in the army.
You can eat some mushy peas in
the Army okay. Joining the army.
Dear William no fun.
I'll skip all the ass kissing since you
blow through all your both through on
your reads anyway. All right. I'm a 34
year old married guy former Navy vet.
Bah bah bah bah who's sick
of feeling like a shit bag.
I want to do something with my life
and feel like making a difference.
I've kicked around the idea of going
back into the military for a while now.
And it's shit or get off the pot time
while you go back into the military.
34.
Okay I brought this up to my wife in
the past and all she can say is you're
married and changes the subject.
Some back story on us.
We've been together for seven
years and married five ish.
We've had our ups and downs
like any couple but I get
sick of being treated like
a child when it comes to my own life.
Anyway I'm just about at the cutoff age
cutoff age wise to go down the path I
want in life.
I want to be a combat medic.
Jesus Christ dude.
Good Lord man.
I mean how much excitement
do you need in your life.
You already served and you want to go
begging with this guy's a friggin hero
here said I'm a determined man who cares
about my family and my family and my
country. I've done my research
and I have the time to join.
Do the medic training go to
rasp Ranger assessment program.
You're gonna become an Army Ranger at 34.
Do you guys ever watch that documentary
on Netflix about it just to see if
you're worthy of going through like the
week long of 10 days or 14 days a hell.
Only thing I remember was they had this
giant like telephone pole that you and
ten other guys had to hold up
and do curls with it or some shit
and his people quit.
The rest of you had to hold the thing up.
I mean I was screaming
in pain watching it.
And if you puked in the pit you had
to get your puke out of the pit.
It was just like just that beginning
thing was more obstacles than I've ever
faced in my entire life.
You are a driven man.
You're a special kind of person man.
If you can't get special forces right
he says then special operations combat
medic training.
My question is Bill what do I do here.
Do I risk losing her or
stay here and resent her.
I don't want to do either but I also can't
continue to work myself to death as a
construction worker making someone
else rich at the cost of my health and
happiness.
Dude if you want to be a combat medic
and you're fucking putting drywall in.
I mean that's gonna be torturing you.
He said I've worked seven twelves for
six months sixty seven days a week 12
hours a day for six goddamn months trying
to save money to go to nursing school
she tells me she booked us on a cruise.
She spent that money on a cruise.
Oh yeah.
Oh boy.
I don't know what to do
and I need your help.
Thanks in advance for your advice and
thanks for the minute mediocre job on
efforts of family.
Go fuck yourself.
I deal to
what's going on in your relationship
but as is is a critical lack of
communication.
OK. You're telling her what you want to
do. She's just saying you're married.
Changes the subject you've saved up all
that money to go to nursing school and
either she didn't realize that that
was what it was for and booked you on a
cruise
or
she's one of the most selfish people on
the planet which I don't think you would
have brought that up.
So I think what's going on
here is you're one of these.
You're this guy's guy John Wayne type.
And like most of them you
know people like that.
You ask me how you're doing and
you just say fine. All right.
Well you need to do
what you got to open up.
You got to sit down you've got
to say listen we've got to talk.
And you have to sit down and
tell her what you want to do.
Tell her how you feel at work and you
have to communicate and start there and
work your way
to the ranger assessment program.
That's what you have to do
because other than that
you have a major blow out
argument on the horizon.
And her catchphrase is going to be
where is all of this coming from
you know.
You if you're one of those guys that does
stuff the right way there's a problem.
You can run into where you
have this expectation that
everybody else should also
do things the right way and when they
don't then you get fucking pissed and it's
all of it builds it is complete.
Like I lead by example and all that shit
you've got to learn how to communicate.
So yeah I would sit down with her
and I would talk to her. All right.
And good luck with that.
Those are amazing friggin goals.
I just want to learn how
to play Tommy the cat.
That's what I want to do
anyways.
That's the podcast everybody.
I hope you enjoyed it.
By the way I have
I have a number of friends on that show
I'm dying up here and they're telling me
that is good as the pilot
was it just keeps getting
better and better and better.
And there's a zillion shows out there
so they really need people to watch.
The book was fucking incredible I know
Jim Carrey's names attached to it so I
know it's gonna be great.
I'm gonna watch Episode 2 right now.
Al Madrigal the great Al Madrigal
who I know do the all things
comedy podcast network
with and he's just a friend
and general is killing it on there.
I don't know. I hope you guys watch
the show because I'm I'm really
I really I'm really enjoying it I'm
enjoying a family vacation all right.
So what are we gonna do here.
Is there anything else I need to fucking
do anything else that I need to hype
here.
Should I give a shout out.
To anything I already gave a shout
out to flee for saving the bees.
I wonder if enough
people fucking did that.
You know I still can't believe that I
pulled photosynthesis out of my age and in
a way I came up with that one.
All right that's it.
Everybody check out I'm dying up here
and I'll check in on you on on what is it
Thursday. Is that what it
is. Is that what it is.
Oh Andrew Santino is on it here we go
Eric Griffin I'm going to get everybody
John Daly fucking hilarious.
Well Sue Wells scroll and Rick Overton
Rick Overton met him back in the day
speaking of neutron dance was actually
in Beverly Hills Cop dorm my rare is
fucking hilarious on it.
I'm gonna watch that right now.
That's what I'm doing after
I upload this podcast.
All right everybody I hope everyone
all the dads out there had a wonderful
Father's Day was incredible day for me
to finally get texts and tweets from
people wish me a happy Father's Day it
meant a lot to me. Thank you so much.
That is it. I will check in
overnight. Check it out. There you go.
That's how you see it on
Thursday. All right. Bye by.